Auf welchen Podcast können sie am ehesten verzichten? Immer wenn ich auf die Straße gehe, drücke ich im Streaming an die Tafel. Du fragst mich, was hörst du denn so? B-O-D-K-S-U-F-O Hey Leute, herzlich willkommen hier. B-O-D-K-S-U-F-O Hey, herzlich willkommen zur alternativen Podcast-Lösung. Wir sind antikapitalistisch, antiapokalyptisch. Wir sind gegen den da oben, okay? Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Gegen den da oben, gegen Olaf. Hier, ich bin Kretze und das ist Panko mir gegenüber. Zecke. Wir freuen uns sehr, dass ihr da seid. Ihr müsst ja niemandem hören sagen, dass ihr uns hört. Nein. Wir sind eine Underground-Organisation. Ich sag mal so, euer Button an der Kutte sagt genug aus. Wir haben ja eigentlich Punk... Unsere Farben sind rot, blau, khaki. Wir sind das Podcast-Ufo. Magenta zum Arbeitstag. Ja, wir haben ja eigentlich Punk zu Grabe getragen. Wer, wann? Thais, unsere damalige Praktikantin, mittlerweile... Hat den Punk getötet, das wusste ich noch. Hat den Punk tot geglaubt. B B. hat ihn versucht wiederzubeleben, hat Mund zu Mund beatmet, aber der Punk wachte nicht mehr auf. Der Punk kam jede Hilfe zu spät. Er war leider bis heute vorüber, ihm wurde die Luft weggedrückt. Nicht so Simon, zum Glück, Simon hält noch mit verschiedensten Röhren und Flüssigkeiten, die sich durch den schlaffen Körper von Punk pumpen lassen. Den Künstlern leben. Aber das ist nicht die Frage, eher ob man es jetzt mal sein lassen sollte. Ja, ich weiss nicht, ob das die Frage ist, mit der wir jetzt den Podcast beginnen wollen, ob wann Leben, also wann ist Leben ein, also wann ist ein Ende? Ich möchte gerne diese Folge, weil wir die letzten Folgen, es geht schon so ein bisschen organisch in diese Richtung. Sterbehilfete. Deswegen möchte ich heute gerne die Richtung Sterbehelfelte, thematisch. Und es zeichnet sich schon seit mehreren Dutzend Folgen tatsächlich ab. Es zeichnet sich ab und ich spreche es mal einfach an, ich nenne es beim Namen, das Kind. Wie lange sollte man Menschenkünste hier im Leben halten? Und diese Frage möchte ich dir jetzt stellen. Ja gut, Stichwort Walt Disney. Stichwort Walt Disney. Hat er es nicht übertrieben, der jetzt schon mehrere Jahrzehnte in der Kryokammer hängt, da rumhängt, wie sein Leib immer noch versorgt mit Kosten in der Kryptokammer. Ich denke persönlich nach, es war nicht mehr in der Kryptokammer und drehe an den Reglern und versuche Verkaufen, Kaufen, Du schürfst selber Bitten, Du schürfst Coins, habe ich gehört. Ich habe bis heute nicht so ganz verstanden wie das mit dem mining funktioniert genau ich auch nicht ist das nicht wie geld drucken nein lass uns einfach die bettik über den kopf ziehen und wir verstecken uns und niemand muss es wissen dass wir keine ahnung haben ich finde es schön dass wir immer wieder beieinander übernachten, ist wie damals eine Übernachtungsparty.
Du Stefan, kann ich dir was sagen? Ja. Ich weiss nicht, was der Unterschied zwischen Weihnachten und Heiliger Abend ist. Psch, psch, psch, psch, ich auch nicht. Ich weiss auch nicht, was der Unterschied zwischen Christkind und Weihnachtsmann ist. Ich weiss auch nicht, was der Unterschied zwischen ...
Hör auf, hör auf! Du, Stefan, ich weiss auch nicht, was der Unterschied zwischen Christkind und Weihnachtsmann ist. Ich weiß auch nicht, was der Unterschied zwischen Nikolaus und Weihnachtsmann ist. Sag mal, hakt's ihr beiden? Mama! Sag mal, hakt's? Sag mal, spinnt ihr? Spinnt ich morgen so früh aus? Mama, wir waren doch ganz leise. Und ihr seid nur am Lachen. Sag mal, habt ihr das Schaden? Wir waren doch ganz leise. Ihr seid nur am Lachen. Habt ihr das Scham? Wir waren noch ganz leise. Habt ihr das Scham? Habt ihr das Scham? Was da, warum ist richtig schwindelig? Was da an Luftverbraten wird? Bitte vorsichtig, es kann zu Kohlenmonoxidmangel kommen. Boah, mir ist es richtig schwindelig. Wenn ihr euch schlecht fühlt, wenn ihr euch schwindelig fühlt, dann checkt bitte nochmal den Kohlenmonoxid-Haushalt und holt euch so einen Melder, damit ihr wissen, was los ist. Hat jeder Notarzt tatsächlich am Körper, trägt einen Kohlenmonoxid-Melder, der immer ... Das ist der Apple Watch. Nee, ich glaube, es ist nochmal so ein extra, wie so eine Pfeife. Das ist ein Whoop-Armband. Es ist ein Whoop-Armband, das dann immer Mambo No. 5 spielt, wenn der Kohlenmonoxid-Gehalt zu hoch ist. Ein Freund von mir hat jetzt ein Whoop-Armband und schwört darauf. Die Idee ist ein bisschen, dein Stresslevel zu tracken und Erholung zu tracken und natürlich auch Schritte, die du gehst. Ist also ein bisschen so ein, sagen wir mal, nicht Fitness, sondern Health-Armband. Kennst du das schon mal von Whoop gehört? Ich weiß nicht, was der Unterschied zwischen Fitness und Health ist. Hä? Seine Sportliebe, das andere ist, man kommt ja auch ohne Sport durchs Leben.
Da sagen wir durch Ernährung oder stressfreiem Leben.
Ich komme nicht ohne Sport durchs Leben.
Bei dir weiss ich, du bist ein Sportjunk.
Ich brauche Snooker, ich brauche Snooker, ich brauche Golf, ich brauche das Zeug.
Du brauchst deinen Kram, du brauchst Schach und du brauchst dein ferngesteuertes Hobby.
Wo du ferngesteuert einen Dackel durch die Gegend zu. Der bei der Robo-Dackel-Show antritt gegen viele andere Roboterhunde. Ja, jedenfalls der hat gecheckt, was ich schon lange glaube, mit Fakten, empirisch belegt, TikTok hilft nicht zur Entspannung. Man denkt ja immer nach einem anstrengenden Arbeitstag oder so, Frauen und Kinder sind aus dem Haus, ich lege mich erst mal auf die Couch. Die sind abends aus dem Haus? Man denkt entweder nach dem langen Arbeitstag oder andere Szenario, sorry, ich habe den nicht so schnell, oder Frauen und Kinder sind morgens aus dem Haus, Kinder, das Kind ist zur Kita gebracht, Frau geht zur Arbeit, ich bin endlich wieder alleine, leg mich auf die Couch, erstmal TikTok. Und da glaube ich eben, dachte ich, ah, das ist natürlich wahnsinnig entspannend, man nimmt es ja als Entspannungs, weiß nicht, also Freizeit wahr. Und man guckt sich das kurz an und scrollt durch, dem ist nicht so. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Wupp sagt Stresswebel fährt nicht runter. Kommt natürlich auch darauf an, was man sich anschaut. Also wenn du dir jetzt wirklich so diese ganzen Knet-Videos anguckst oder so, oder wenn du halt so Ragebait und so, guck dir mal an, was die da wieder verbrechen da oben. Ragebait. Dann ist was anderes. Ich habe ein Video letztens gesehen auf TikTok, das hat mich sehr entspannt. Welches? Und zwar, was ich gerne gucke, sind Kochparodien. Also Gackiges Kochen, also wirklich Kochen, aber auch Lachen. Das ist für mich die perfekte Kombination, die es braucht. Und du kennst ja vielleicht, also das ist so ein Kochvideo. Wie Kochen und Lachen. Ich finde, beim Kochen ist nichts, mir zu lachen zu machen. Naja, also der macht erstmal einen Schnitzel, dann schneidet er es in kleine Stücke, rollt die Stücke in Wrap, einen Schnitzelwrap. Dann schneidet er diesen Wrap wieder in Scheiben, brät die Scheiben an an der Pfanne. Schnitzel, Wrap, Buletten. Dann schmeißt er die angebratenen Schnitzelwrap-Buletten in den Mixer, rührt das alles zusammen, formt daraus so kleine Würste, schmeißt die in die Fritteuse. Dann hat er die aus der Fritteuse, dann schneidet er wieder in Stücke, dann macht er die in Salat. Dann packt er den Salat, packt ihn wieder in den Rap rein. Und so geht das immer und immer und immer weiter.
Und das wieder geht zwei Stunden.
Und es kommt nie, und man weiss nicht, wann dieses Gericht zu Ende ist, und man denkt sich einfach, was ist gerade der physische Zustand, der Aggregatszustand dieses ursprünglichen Schnitzels.
Das ist einfach zu stark verarbeitet, Das ist einfach immer noch mal verarbeitet. Es ist ganz fantastisch. Schnitzelgas, ist es am Ende dann tatsächlich nur noch? Oder so Edelgas? Einzelne Moleküle Schnitzel sind da noch drin. Und das hat mich entspannt auf jeden Fall. Ja, das verstehe ich, das würde mich auch entspannen. Oder wütend machen. Bei mir, die Kochvideos sind dann, da schneidet sich ein Junge an so einem Gurkenschneider und da muss er ins Krankenhaus, weil seine Fingerkuppe weg ist. Das ist so meine For You-Page. Isst man dann noch den Salat, ist die Frage. Isst man den herrlichen Gurkensalat, wenn am Ende dein Kind noch ein bisschen Fingerkuppe reingeschmitten hat? Nicht, wenn du vegan unterwegs bist. Mein Name ist Stefan Thies, von mir ist Florian Will. Wir freuen uns auf diese neue uns auf diese neue Folge Das Podcast UFO, nämlich, wir haben jetzt inzwischen auch schon eine Folge. So, 439, da möchten wir sagen, denn ich habe mitbekommen, für mexikanische Kartelle ist diese Zahl 439 keine unbedeutende Zahl. 439 bedeutet so viel wie, du bist im Tode geweiht. Ja, ich kenne es Spanisch nicht so gut, aber das scheint ein Satz zu sein, wenn man das ausspricht, so wie Esel, wenn man das auf den Taschen schreibt, sieben drei fünf drei. So ist vier drei neun in España. So wie May the Fourth. Genau, sowas in der Ecke. Wir lachen jetzt, aber tatsächlich viele Todgeweihte kriegen diese Zahl und deswegen wird das als böses Omen auch genannt. Deswegen möchten wir uns jetzt von allen mexikanischen Kartellen freimachen, indem wir sagen, wir nehmen diese Zahl ernst. Wir lachen nicht drüber über 439, da ist überhaupt nichts jetzt Gackiges dran. Also jetzt, hey, hey, hey, nein, nee, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp.
Nein, also wenn du, nein.
Nein, nein, Stefan, Stefan, Stefan, Stefan, Stefan, Stefan. Wir schauen uns die Zahlen einfach mal komplett neutral an, okay? Okay.
Also.
So, jetzt haben wir es spielten. Was ist er, haft er, haft er, haft er.
Genn auf die Autorados!
Wurden, wurde die Mutter jetzt erschossen?
Ja. Die Mutter, die kommt und sagt, sei leiser. Die anderen sind immer noch unter der Decke und verstecken sich. Und dann ist es so eine Harry-Potter-Situation, dass der mit ansehen musste, wie seine Mutter erschossen wurde. Und dann geht das Abenteuer eigentlich erst richtig los, das war nur die Einleitung. Wenn du immer bei den Filmpitches einfach mir direkt ins Gesicht gähnst, ist das für mein Selbstverständlich auch nicht ideal, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Nee, nee, ich finde deine Filmtipps immer, Pitches, sorry, immer richtig gut und nee, die bringen mich zum Nachdenken und zum Weinen hoffentlich. Da geht eher darum, dass man Gehirn, ist nicht gähnen, ein Gehirn durchlüften oder ist das so ein Urban Myth? Also warum gähnt man Sauerstoffgehalt im Blutmusten? Sauerstoffgehalt zu niedrig, man muss mal rein oder man ist einfach komplett gelangweilt und oder ist kurz vorm Einschlafen. Ist denn Langeweile gleich gähnen, ist das wirklich noch haltbar? Ja, ich glaube schon. Ich habe tatsächlich lange Zeit ja Schwierigkeiten gehabt zu gähnen und wahrscheinlich, wenn wir so viel über das Gähnen reden, dann ist dieser Reflex auch wieder da. Aber ich hatte immer das Gefühl, dass ich nicht über die Klippe oben komme. Es kommt wie Nieser. Also ich komme hoch, aber ich schaffe den Sprung, den Übersprung dann nicht so. Das ist teilweise, wenn du auch, sagen wir mal, jetzt sage ich mal, defikierst. Ja, also jetzt im weitesten Sinne. Also wenn du jetzt abkotest. Wenn du abkotest. Weil wenn du sagst, im weitesten Sinne, verstehe ich es weniger. Weil wenn du etwas sehr klar formulierst. Im sehr engen Sinne rede ich vom Abkoten. Weil wenn du etwas sehr klar formulierst und dann sagst, im weitesten Sinne, macht es das auf eine Art Unklar. Aha, okay, ich verstehe. Also ich meine Dienstag im weitesten Sinne. Eine kleine Stilkritik. Okay, gut, das muss auch sein. Ja, vier, drei, neun. Beim Abquoten ist es ja auch manchmal so, dass du, sag ich mal, nicht den Sprung schaffst. Du kommst nicht ganz drüber und dann geht's wieder rein. Du meinst, wenn man einen ordentlich wegscheißt und dann ist aber an irgendeinem Punkt du merkst. Wenn es so eine Rautenform hat und man kommt nicht ganz über den Höhepunkt, über den Hochpunkt und dann geht's wieder rein und parkt wieder ein fürs nächste Mal. Der Wachsmalstift. Der einmal kurz rauskommt, meinst du? Der Lippenstift. Aha, ja, ich habe jetzt nicht so viel mit Lippenstift zu tun, aber haben die auch so einen Punkt, wo man dann ... Nee, aber die kommen ja wieder rein. Also die machst du auch aus und wieder rein. Ach so, die kommen ja rein, ja, ja. Aber die können viel mit Lippenstippen zu tun, aber haben die auch so einen Punkt, wo man dann ...
Nee, aber die kommen ja wieder rein. Also die macht so aus und wieder rein.
Ach so, die kommen ja rein, ja, ja. Aber die können auch nochmal einparken.
Die sagen mal Hallo und dann gehen sie wieder rein.
Dann für morgen. Der guckt schon mal so ein bisschen ins Wasser, ist noch zu kalt, geht nochmal in die Dusche.
Wie so eine Muschel.
Wie eine Muschel, genau. Die streckt die Zunge raus und sagt, nee, heute nicht.
Heute bleibe ich noch im Haus drin.
Immer im Häuslein. Muschel, auch geilstes Tier, oder? Geilstes Tier? Super gutes Tier. Platz drei, Max. Gut, aber bei 16 Millionen Tieren ist Platz drei Max schon mal relativ gut. Das ist schlecht, aber das beste Tier? Ja, es ist einfach so ein Einzeltier in einem Haus. Ich finde die immer, also würden die sich gut mit dem Einsiedlerkrebs verstehen oder so, oder sind es so Nachbarn, sind es komplett unterschiedliche Wesen, weil es ist ja so manchmal, wie wenn man sagt, so keine Ahnung, zwei Leute, die das gleiche T-Shirt anhaben, grüssen sich oder so. Und es ist so ein Einsiedlerkrebs, eine Schildkröte und eine Muschel. Haben die irgendeine Baseline, können die über irgendwas reden oder ist es Schweigen auf der Party? Baseline.
Aber ohne Witz, wenn du eine Unterwasserband besetzen müsstest, würde doch die Muschel den Bass spielen. Diese Frage hat Ariel für uns beantwortet und ich meine nicht. Wer spielt da den Bass? Das können wir jetzt herausfinden. Naja, wahrscheinlich der Bass, oder? Es gibt doch den Bass als Fisch. Was ist denn der Bass auf Deutsch? So, wir hören kurz rein in den ... Wir haben die Gemma lieb, wir haben nichts gegen die Gemma. Genau, aber Ariel, listen to me. The human world, it's a mess. Life under the sea is better than anything they got up there. Achtung, ich singe. Just look at the world around you, right here on the ocean floor, such wonderful things surround you, what more is you looking for? Under the sea, under the sea, darling it's better, down where it's wetter, wo sie nämlich sagen, so, the nude play the flute, the carp play the harp, the plays play the bass. The plays? P-L-A-I-C-E geschrieben. So, das ist nämlich die Scholle, demnach debunked. Florentin wurde mal wieder debunked. Ich kann mir das nicht mehr leisten. Du kannst es nicht mehr leisten. Ich kann mir das wirklich nicht mehr oft leisten. Ja, ich weiß.
Beim Dritten bist du hier raus.
Ich bin knietief drin gerade.
Die Scholle spielt den Bass.
Auch hier, grossen Respekt an die Übersetzer.
The Newt play the flute.
Also hier wird es schwierig.
Wir gucken mal, wie es übersetzt wurde.
Das ist wieder so eine Übersetzungshölle,
so ein Übersetzungs-Marianne-Graben,
wo wir uns jetzt gerade befinden,
wo wirklich das auf Wortspielen an. Aber es ist ja nicht mal ein Wortspiel, es reimt sich einfach nur. Da kannst du ja sagen, der Bass was der Bass, oder was ist es? Welches Wassertier reimt sich auf Bass? Der Seetank blüht immer grüner, wenn er dich von fern erfreut. Wirklich, das ist der Text? Unter dem Meer. So, und jetzt, aber das Problem ist ja, auf einer Bildebene siehst du ja die Schollen, die Bass spielen. Gut, jetzt weiss so ein achtjähriges Kind nicht notwendigerweise, was eine Scholle ist. Ich glaube, man kann dem guten Hering auch als Scholle unterschieben. Ich glaube, da werden die wenigsten Kleinkinder aufschreien und sagen,
sag mal, also da ist ja wirklich anatomisch einiges an der falschen Stelle. Ich zitiere.
Die Kröt spielt die Flöt,
die Larv zupft die Harf,
die Brass schlägt
den Bass.
So, und jetzt haben wir mit Brass
natürlich
die Larv spielt die Harf,
die Brachse sozusagen, was kein Schollenfisch, sondern ein Karpfenfisch ist. Die Larve spielt die Harf? Die Larve? Das ist nicht mein eigenes Tier. Das ist wie wenn du sagst Baby. Weißt du, wovon denn? Larve ist ja irgendwas, kann eine Fliege sein oder irgendwas anderes oder eine Mücke. Warum nicht der Lack spielt den Bass? Mein Gott, dann machen wir es halt unrein. Ja, oder die Frage ist halt, ab welchem Punkt sagst du, wir ändern das Instrument? Da sagst du, wir machen die Trompete und das ist dann der ... Haben sie ja. Na, ich weiß nicht, Kaviar spielt Klavier oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Aber ich finde das ... Kaviar, das Gericht. Okay, du bist bei Ratatouille. Ach, sorry, jetzt war ich kurz abgebogen. Ratatouille singen die Kröten, äh, die Farotten, die Flöten. Was? Da spielt der Celery, der Stitcheridoo! Aber es ist schon unangenehm, ne?
Also, angenommen jetzt Fische,
angenommen Fische kämen an die Macht
und würden ja wahrscheinlich als Hymne dieses Lied nehmen.
Weil in diesem Lied geht es ja darum,
die Wasserbewohner sind besser, haben es besser
und machen es besser als die Landbewohner.
So, das ist ja deren Hymne.
Aber es wurde ja geschrieben von einem Ländling. Nee, von Sebastian, in der Diagese von Sebastian der Krabbe. Ja, aber nur in der Diagese. Ich rede jetzt von der Exegese. Non-diagetisch ist der Song geschrieben. So kommst du nicht drum rum, so kommst du nicht drum. Das ist so ein bisschen wie, es gibt ja die französische Unabhängigkeitshymne, die Marseillais. Und die Franzosen waren aber halt auch harte Kolonialherren einfach, die andere Völker unterdrückt haben in anderen Ländern der Welt. Und die haben dann nach Unabhängigkeit gekämpft gegen die Franzosen und hatten als Kampflied gegen die Franzosen die Marseillais, die Unabhängigkeitshymne, so dass die französischen Truppen gegen eine Armee gekämpft haben, die die Marseillais singen. Ganz ehrlich, die Marseillais, und da wünsche ich mir wirklich mal eine Studie zu, weil es wird ja immer noch vor, vor dem Fussballspiel, also sagen wir, machen wir es grösser, vor Sportveranstaltungen wird ja immer noch die Nationalhymne gesungen. Ja. Und die Nationalhymne hatte ja früher mal in Kriegszeiten, wenn die so lange besteht wie die Marseillers, die ja sehr blutig, sehr marsch, sehr nach vorne, los geht's an die Waffenvölker, vereinigt euch und so, hat er schon gewisse Zwecke gehabt. Nämlich wahrscheinlich Endorphin, Adrenalin, pushend geht nach vorne. Ich glaube, die Marseilles, aber auch Fratelli d'Italia.
Es gibt so ein paar Hymnen, auch die portugiesische Hymne, die gehen ordentlich nach vorne.
Und ich glaube, Mannschaften mit einer geilen, nach vorne gehenden Hymne haben bessere Chancen auf den Sieg.
Ich meine auch, die brasilianische Hymne ist auch so pushend.
Ich würde gerne, und dann sozusagen, jetzt Versuchsaufbau. Wir sagen, wir beräumen dieses Länderspiel an, wir trainieren dafür. Wir als Forscher wissen, das Länderspiel wird nie stattfinden, sondern wir steilen es voll. Fans wissen, es ist auch ein Geweiss, oder nicht? Die denken aber, dass das Spiel stattfindet. Also die Fußballer wissen, dass das Spiel findet statt. Denken. Okay. Und dann singen die Nationalhymne und dann kommen Ärzte in Kitteln und ganz schnell wird denen Blut abgenommen. Ah, zwischen Spiel und Hymne. Nein, direkt nach der Hymne, unmittelbar nach der Hymne. Das Spiel wird nicht stattfinden. Also das Spiel findet, warum darf das nicht stattfinden? Das darf nicht stattfinden. Deswegen fühlt sich teuer. Aber dein wissenschaftlicher Eingriff ist immer so hart, dass einfach so ein Fussballspiel nicht stattfindet. Die Leute freuen sich drauf. Warum darf das nicht stattfinden? Warum kommt einfach Blut ... Das ist zu teuer. Das ist zu teuer. Hätte doch einfach stattgefunden, wenn du nicht eingegriffen hättest. Ja, aber es ist zu teuer. Wir können das nicht ... Aber wir sind alle da. Es gibt keinen Ball. Messi hat den Kalender frei für den Tag. Wir haben keinen Ball. Wir haben keinen Ball. Und kein Schiedsrichter. Es wird doch irgendjemand im Stadion einen Ball dabei haben. Schiedsrichter ist ein Schiedsrichter. Holen wir wieder einen Schiedsrichter aus dem Publikum, haben die doch auch gemacht bei der WM. Die Tore waren aus Plastik, die wir da aufgestellt haben. Warum hat das keine... Stadion ist voll, Stadion ist komplett voll. Alle haben gezahlt fürs Ticket. Okay, Alternativvorschlag. Wir laden Mannschaften ein, Spanien gegen Portugal, so der El Clasico. Und dann sagen wir aber, hey, singt eine andere Hymne. Und dann... Wie, wem? Wir sagen den Spaniern, singt die portugiesische Hymne und wer sagt den Portugiesen, singt die spanische Hymne. Wann nehmen wir Blut ab? Und dann, nach dem Spiel, nehmen wir von jedem im Publikum Blut ab und schauen, ob die überrascht sind über das Ergebnis am Überraschungshormon und können gucken, ah, haben die anders gespielt als erwartet. Im Durchschnitt ermittelt sich das ja wieder. Ja, ich würde denen gerne an vielen Punkten Blut abnehmen. Erst mal, was ist meine Frage, Blut eigentlich überhaupt? Ja, das ist nochmal Frage eins, da hätten wir vielleicht nochmal vorher drüber reden können. Also was ist der Zweck, warum ist es rot? Solche Sachen. Aber ich möchte gerne wissen, gibt es sowas wie Testosteron, also Fussballer, männliche Fussballspieler haben nachweislich mehr Testosteron im Blut, wenn sie ein Heimspiel haben. Was natürlich spannend ist, weil Testosteron setzt ja ungeahnte Kräfte frei, wie man den Wissenschaftler sagt. Und deswegen kann ich mir vorstellen, dass so die Marseillers setzt mehr ungeahnte Kräfte frei als, sagen wir mal, die boring ass holländische Hymne, die ja wirklich universally disliked ist. Die einfach generell vom Text her, setz dich auf die Couch, leg die Beine hoch, in Holland Holland, Käse, Cracker, Käse, Cracker. Wir brauchen ohnehin neue Hymnen und man muss natürlich gucken, dass die in ihre Hymnen nicht absichtlich Fussball einbauen. Weil wenn die sagen, man macht eine neue Hymne jetzt hier irgendwie so Belgien, lass uns da mal so reinbauen, so schieß noch ein Tor, schieß noch ein Tor, weil wir Hymnen fast ausschließlich vor Fussballspielen. Das ist ja eine Hymne für das ganze Land. Warum bist du so verschwörerisch? Hey, du bist so verschwörerisch. Du bist Bartels, du bist Uwe Bartels. Nee, die Komponente ist sehr blatter. Ach, du meinst Klaus Bartelt. Du bist Klaus Bartelt. Klaus, bau doch in die Hymne mal so ein bisschen, schiess links oben, schiess links oben ins Tor, grätsch den weg, den anderen.
Den Sack.
Den Sack, ja, feuer den mal richtig auf, okay? Ich dachte, ich soll eine Hymne für Belgien schreiben. Ja, ich meine, obwohl die alte perfekt war. Ich meine, aber die hört man ja hauptsächlich nur vor Fussballspielen. Ja, aber vor dem Olympischen Spiel. So richtig so, Belgien, ihr seid die Geilsten, schießt das Tor, eures Lebens. So was, kannst du so was? Ja. Ne, ich kann primär. Fucking Klaus, niemand kann es mehr hören. Und dann nimmt der den Ball und schießt den Tor. Ach, heute ist aber auch wieder so eine Döner-Folge, ich habe auch wieder einen Döner-Intus. Ich spüre, dass du schwerer bist. Ich bin quasi eine Fleischtaschentasche. Ich fühle mich selbst nur als Teil einer großen Fleischtaschenordnung. Das Fleisch kommt in den Döner und der Döner kommt in mich. Und ich bin jetzt Teil dieses ganzen Systems. Frage, hast du denn einen guten Mangal-Lukas-Bodolski-Döner, LP-10-Döner genommen? Nein, nein, nein. Ich habe tatsächlich heute das erste Mal Döner mit ein bisschen scharf genommen, weil ich versuche wieder ein bisschen mehr Schärfe in mein Leben zu bringen. Ich habe mir allerdings jetzt einen Pulli ruiniert mit meiner Hot Sauce, weil ich die Hot Sauce immer schüttel, bevor ich sie reinballer in verschiedenste Ger Gerichte. Und den habe ich mir jetzt komplett über den Pulli geballert. Auch nach mehrmaligem Waschen ging es nicht raus, sodass der Pulli jetzt mich wirklich mit grossen Augen angeguckt hat, als ich ihn in die Mülltonne gestopft habe. So, der ist raus, Pulli ist raus. Langjährige Zuschauer werden wahrscheinlich nach einigen Wochen rausfinden können, welcher meiner Pullis es ist. Ja, der habe zwei und jetzt habe ich nur noch einen. Und jetzt habe ich ein bisschen Problem. Ich habe allerdings noch einen anderen Pulli, aber ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, dass man manchmal in Momenten von Hybris und Selbstverwirklichung Dinge kauft, die man dann aber sich nicht traut zu benutzen. Du meinst, du hast sie bereits gekauft, sind in deinem Besitz und dann traust du sich nicht die Besitz. Ja, ich habe einen Pulli gekauft. Also bei Klamotten war es in meiner Schulzeit oft der Fall, dass ich irgendwie in der Freizeit ungeahnte Selbstbewusstsein entwickelt habe, etwas zu kaufen, wo ich dann dachte, eine karierte Hose? Bestimmt sich die karierte Hose, vergiss es, niemals sich diese karierte Hose an. Was ist, wenn Carina die karierte Hose sieht? Aber das ist der Flamboyen Stefan, der in der Freizeit immer gedacht hat, ich gestalte die Welt und die Welt gestaltet mich, ich tanze auf dieser Welt herum und sie ist meins und in der Schulzeit war ich immer, ja, ja, Sir und hab natürlich nicht die karierte Hose angezogen. Genau so geht es mir auch. Womit denn? Ich habe in einem Anflug von Hybris und modischen Krawall, quasi einer modischen Explosion, die man wahrscheinlich in vielen Orten in Mailand noch gespürt hat, in der Modehauptstadt, habe ich mir einen hellblauen Pullover gekauft, auf den eine große Ente ich weiß nicht, so gestickt, aber wie so
pelzig so ein bisschen, und in
Pelz, ähm, aus Pelz eine Ente
und die Ente hat den Schnabel
auf und Nerz,
Pelz, eine Ente. Und dann
neben dem Schnabel ist noch
eine grosse Sprechblase, auch aus
Pelz. Pelz.
Und in dieser Sprechblase steht
Wow. Erstmal klingt das wie, lass ich eine Sache sagen, es klingt nicht wie etwas, was Florentin Will nicht tragen würde. Ah, okay, das ist doch schon mal gut. Das ist schon mal gut, dass ich das als Feedback kriege. Dann kann ich mich schon mal langsam annähern. Was ein bisschen neudeutsch Off-Putting daran ist, ist die Vorstellung des hellblauen. Wobei es sehr gut zu deinen kalten, eisigen Augen passen würde. Okay, dankeschön, ja. Vielleicht könnte man das mal ausprobieren. Du hast eisblaue Augen. Aber es hat keine Kapuze. Ich bin ja sonst immer Kapuzen verwöhnt, weswegen ich auch als der Bucklige bekannt bin, weil ich dann unter der Jacke immer da diesen Buckel habe, aber vielleicht, jetzt bin ich gezwungen, mich modisch mal so ein bisschen aus meiner Muschelschale heraus zu bewegen, hin zur Gans, habe ich Ente gesagt, Gans, die sagt, wow. Aber das ist die alte Ente-Gans-Diskussion, die wir haben und ich jetzt auch nicht wieder aufmachen müsste, damals sind Fäuste geflogen und es wurden Hotlines angerufen. Das muss alles nicht mehr sein. Also Ente und Gans sind ... Ente, Gans, Schwan ist alles von mir aus, alles in einem Beutel drin. Es ist alles in einem Beutel drin. Okay. Der Schwan spielt die Pan. Oh, sehr gut. Flöte. Ja, der Schwan mag Marzipan. Dann für Ratatouille. Wiederum. Man muss zu jedem Tier ein Instrument und was zu essen finden. Für Ratatouille, Ratatouille und Arielle. Arielle und Ratatouille. Ich war ein Wochenende in Brüssel. Brüssel. Welche Chymne hast du da gehört? Immer wenn ich Klaus Badelt. Weil immer wenn ich Köln verteidige, warum ich in Köln wohne, dann sagen alle, aber Köln, ach, was willst du denn noch in Köln? Du auch, hast mir gesagt, was willst du denn noch hier? Zieh auch weg, zieh auch weg, kommst du hier auch weg. Wo du mich so zur Seite, weißt du noch, als du mich so zur Seite genommen hast und gesagt hast, komm, zieh doch auch weg. Ich glaube, weil du Angst hast, hier was dann zu verpassen, wenn du weg bist und ich bin noch hier. Und hier ist das ganze Leben noch. Ich hätte auch gerne meine Umgebung wieder. Ich mag nicht, dass du wegziehst, aber du hast ja einen kleinen Hilfeschrei auch losgelassen, einen kleinen Sonar, weil du dich ja für dieses Gewinnspiel mit dem unbekannten Haus im Nirgendwo zur Empfindlichkeit gegeben hast. Das heißt, du hast ja schon ein bisschen den Drang nach draußen, oder? Da tickt ja schon die Uhr.
Naja, das hätte ich ja wahrscheinlich vermietet oder sagen wir mal als Ferienhaus, weil das in Sinne genommen. Du hättest das Traumhaus, das du im Gewinnspiel gewonnen hast, vermietet. Also du bist wirklich... Weg damit. Es ist wirklich der langweiligste Traum der Welt. Oh, ich hätte gerne so ein richtig geiles Haus mit Pool und dann so einem Balkon in so einem Wald mit einem See. Um das dann in Zahlung zu geben. Um das dann so richtig für richtig viel Rendite zu verkaufen. Ich wäre sehr deutsch, das Traum aus Vermieten. Ich verteidige Köln, weil es ist nicht die schönste Stadt. Ich mag es ja. Was ist für eine Verteidigung? Du wirst kein guter Anwalt. Gut, es war jetzt illegal, aber ich mag es. Mir hat es gefallen. Ich verteidige Köln immer mit Standortvorteil. Du bist schnell in Paris. Du bist schnell in Belgien. Du bist schnell in Holland. All das, ich bin selten in Paris. Ganz selten. Ich bin auch nie in Holland und auch nie in Belgien und auch eigentlich nie in Paris und nie in Frankreich. Aber jetzt hast du, um dir das selbst zu beweisen, dass das ein gutes Argument ist, hast du das gesagt, jetzt muss ich es auch mal machen. Ich bin zum ersten Mal den Standort Vorteil Köln, SVK, genutzt, um nach Brüssel rüber zu stechen, weil man ist in zwei Stunden Autofahrt, ein bisschen weniger sogar, in Brüssel. Und habe ich sehr genossen, war aber sehr anstrengend, weil Brüssel ist, ich wusste gar nicht, dass Brüssel, also in meinem Kopf habe ich mir das so als einen romantischen Wochenendtrip vorgestellt, aber nein, Brüssel ist wahnsinnig laut, anstrengend, Brüssel ist ein hartes Plaster. Ich war persönlich noch nicht dort, aber ich habe gehört, dass es wirklich, also da ist es wirklich brutal.
Stimmt nicht, in meiner Fahrt nach Frankreich habe ich kurz in Brüssel Zwischenstopp gemacht und habe mir da die französischen Asterix Comics angeguckt, die original französischen Asterix Comics. Hast du die in Belgien angeguckt? Die habe ich mir in Belgien angeguckt, aber das Rhön habe ich auch vernommen, dieses Konstellten Brüsseln sagt man ja, da Brüssel ist dieses Brüssel. Ja, ja.
So in der ganzen Stadt, und du weisst nicht, wo es herkommt.
Die machen es nachts kurz aus für eine Stunde.
Ja, da kannst du kurz mal Schnappatmung, aber dann hast du es wieder, ganz schrecklich. Ich fand es sehr wummern und vibrierend live, aber ich wusste gar nicht, dass es grösser ist als Köln. Das habe ich nie am Schirm gehabt. Das heißt, du hättest auch Standortvorteil, Brüssel bist du schnell in Köln. Ja, genau. Das heißt, man kann es ja auch umdrehen. Das ist ja immer das Ding. Da musst du ja dann quasi ein bisschen geometrisch ein paar Kreise ziehen, was jetzt wirklich am Nähenverhältnis am besten. Wo ich sagen muss, ich verteidige dem nicht Köln, nämlich sage, ich bin in Köln. Ich bin schnell in Köln. Du bist ja Kölner, Junge. Wenn man in Köln wohnt, ist man schnell in Köln. Nee, ich kann Köln, will ich nur empfehlen, wenn man weg ist und dann wieder kommt, dann weiß man zu schätzen. Ja, ich habe heute meinen letzten Tag in Köln. Eben. Ich war gerade noch mal in meiner Wohnung, die schon komplett leer ist. Ich muss da noch ein paar Schlüssel abgleichen, weil ich nicht mehr weiß, welche Schlüssel wofür sind. Also habe ich einfach meinen kompletten Schlüsselbeutel mitgenommen, um jeden einzelnen Schlüssel an der Kellertür abzugleichen. Wer Slack-Nachrichten bekommt, muss sie vorlesen. Lies doch der Klasse vor, was du da bekommen hast. Gut, mein Kollege Anton Klasen von Rocket Beans TV, der YouTube-Channel-Managerager schreibt mir, meh.
Okay.
Das war die Slack-Nachricht der Woche.
Also, er ist nicht begeistert vielleicht von einem Vorschlag, den ich ihm gemacht habe. Das klingt ein bisschen so.
Ja, gut.
Ja, ich bin tatsächlich heute das letzte Mal in Köln gewesen.
Ich bin das letzte Mal die Treppen hochgegangen.
Ich habe immer relativ hoch gewohnt.
Und jetzt das letzte Mal, jetzt wurde schon das Schloss ausgewechselt, was ich nicht wusste,
ich dachte, ich kann noch mal in die leere Wohnung
rein und dachte, ich mache noch mal Fotos
und gehe noch mal rum und nehme noch mal
alles mit und jetzt habe ich tatsächlich
alle Schlüssel abgeglichen, Kellerschlüssel,
habe alles parat, die werde ich jetzt versenden
und dann bin ich raus und
damit ist dieses Kapitel
zu Ende. Dann endlich mal
zu Ende, es zieht sich, also hinten raus,
es zieht sich, also von der ersten,
ich ziehe weg und komme nicht wieder, bis hin zu
Vielen Dank. damit ist dieses Kapitel zu Ende. Dann endlich mal zu Ende. Es zieht sich, also hinten raus, es zieht sich, also von der ersten, ich ziehe weg und komme nicht wieder, bis hin zu, ah, die Schlüssel sind immer noch in deinem Besuch. Und jetzt, da habe ich natürlich viel erlebt in der Wohnung, ne, also da habe ich, ich hatte immer drei Dinge. Naja, ich hatte da so einen Inder, wo ich immer schön Chicken Tikka Masala bestellt habe, mit Reiter und Naan, das waren so die drei Reiter der Apokalypse.
Weder besonders Kölsch, noch besonders dann natürlich Gamescom,
ganz klar, schön über
den Fluss, wie heißt der noch?
Main. Main, immer noch
schön da zur Messe.
Ansonsten, was habe ich hier alles erlebt?
Nehmen wir Ernst, was habe ich
hier alles erlebt?
Also du bist eigentlich überall das Gleiche. Dich kann man irgendwo hinsetzen und du wirst da genau das gleiche Leben führen wie an einem anderen Ort. Also bei dir kann man jetzt gar nicht, deswegen, du kannst überall hinziehen. Du kannst auch in Brüssel sitzen, wirklich. Und dann kannst du da machen, was du machst. Du bist beständig du selbst. Eine wahnsinnig laute Wohnung, muss ich sagen. Direkt zwischen einer Kneipe und einem Bahnhof. Und ich fand das immer, als ich da eingezogen bin, fand ich das so cool, dass man die Gleise gesehen hat. Und das hatte so was Vibrierendes, so was Brüsseliges. Ja, was Brüsselendes. So was Brüsselendes, dass immer so die Züge in der Mitte der Nacht und der fährt nach Barcelona und so und dann die Gleise und dann das Quietschen und so. Das ist die Achtze nach Barcelona. Und das hatte irgendwie was, aber auch recht nervig, ne? Also die ganze Zeit die Züge und dann kam der Wasserschaden, dann war alles vorbei. Aber jetzt bin ich raus, also du bist jetzt eigentlich alleine hier, ne? Okay, ja gut, ich halte hier die Stellung, aber das heißt, ein Aufruf von euch da draußen in Köln ist ein Platz frei. Ja, ein Platz frei, wer in meiner Wohnung nachmieten will, wer nachrücken will, gerne will kommen, es ist wie gesagt ein, ja sagen wir mal, oberflächlich überstrichener Wasserschaden noch in der Wohnung, der lauert. Du hast nicht viel Werbung gemacht für die Wohnung. Ich habe mir ernsthaft überlegt, und ich weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwie rechtliches Gedöns gibt, aber es gab ja Wasserschaden in meiner Wohnung, da über mir hat es getropft, alles durch, komplett bis zur Wohnung unter mir, alles Wasser, Schimmel, abgeplatzt, absolute Hölle. Und dann kam irgendwann der Vermieter und hat das halt übermalt. Du weißt nicht, du bist dir sicher, dass sie es nicht trockengelegt haben.
Ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet.
Ich habe mir selber vom Baumarkt ja habe ich mir so einen Wärmefön
gekauft, habe den Tagsüber laufen lassen,
ohne dass ich da war. Lass mich dir damit sagen, du löst damit
nicht das Problem, das Symptom.
Ja, ja, so, ich glaube, das wurde
nur oberflächlich behandelt, dieses Thema.
Das ist dieser rechtlich relevante
Satzteil Glaube.
So, richtig, weil
ich kenne mich auch einen Kollegen, der meinte,
ah, damals bin ich mit meiner Freundin in die neue Stadt
gezogen, Wohnung, alles super, alles
toll und nach ein paar Wochen haben
wir gemerkt, da wurde ein Wasserschaden
nicht richtig behandelt, wir müssen noch mal komplett
raus, wir müssen ins Hotel, das muss noch mal aufgerissen
werden und ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass so was ähnliches auch
passiert. Und jetzt habe ich,
denke ich mir, soll ich mit dem Vermieter reden so,
sie sagen das aber schon
Interessenten, dass da
einen Wasserschaden gab oder nicht.
Und jetzt habe ich mir überlegt, soll
ich jetzt in einem Monat
oder soll ich in einem Monat
nochmal da klingeln
und sagen, guten Tag, ich bin der Vormieter, Ihnen ist schon klar, dass es hier einen Wasserschaden gab. Soll ich das machen? Oder ist das eher so, dann machen die sich Sorgen, ohne zu wissen, was man dagegen machen kann? Ist es meine moralische Verpflichtung, den Nachmittern das mitzuteilen? Soll ich irgendwo einen Zettel verstecken? Was soll ich machen? Ja, versteck doch, ja, ich finde es gut, versteck doch irgendwo einen Zettel, wo du draufschreibst, aber er ist natürlich als Code, also so ein Enigma-artiges Rätsel, was die so entschlüsseln müssen, so Zodiac-mässig, in so Runenschriften. Achtung, hier ist ein Wasserschaden gewesen. Der wurde nur rudimentär überpinselt. Genau, dann viel Spaß für die Leute, die ihn rudimentär übersetzen müssen. Aber das ist doch nicht so schlecht. Da bin ich das so spielerisch. Ich weiß halt nicht so, ich bin eigentlich nicht der Typ, der irgendwie jetzt die Wahrheit sagt oder so, oder der irgendwie jetzt sagt so Dinge, die man was man nicht weiß, macht dich nicht heiß. So, dass man jetzt Leute warnt oder so, da bin ich eigentlich nicht der Typ für, weil ich denke mir, dann machen die sich Sorgen und man weiss gar nicht warum. Bei einem Wasserschaden gilt der Satz nicht, was du nicht weiss, macht dich nicht heiß, da gilt eher, was du nicht weiss, mach dich langsam krank. Was du nicht weiss, schimmel dir die Bude weg. Was du nicht weiss, gib dir Krebs. Aber dafür gibt es halt kein Sprichwort, ne? Es reimt sich nicht so schön. Eben, und deswegen weiss ich nicht, ob ich dir vertrauen kann, weil es gibt das Sprichwort, was man nicht weiss, macht dich nicht heiß. Und ich bin nicht gerne heiß, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bleib lieber kühl und gelassen. Also, jetzt steht natürlich moralischer Imperativ Kant gegen Sprichwort, man weiss nicht genau. Gegen Wissensücke, also die existierte da auch noch. Ich finde, es ist eine Pflicht für die Gesellschaft beim Auszug oder jetzt bei der Schlüsselübergabe oder sowas zu fragen, ist der Wasserschaden behoben, wurde der inzwischen behoben? Ja, dann sagt der Vermittlung, ja, ja, klar, natürlich, das ist alles in Ordnung, das haben die mit grösster Sorgfalt und Vorsicht gemacht. Ja, aber dann kannst du nichts mehr machen. Schachmant, du bist Schachmant, dann bist du Schachmant. Ich frage mich nur, muss der den Nachmietern sagen, übrigens, hier gab es vor ein paar Monaten Wasserschaden. Nee, wenn er behoben ist, nein. Aber so, das ist das Ding, das ist ja was, das ich liefern könnte als Wissen, zu sagen, übrigens, hier gab es einen Wasserschaden, falls ihr alle krank werdet, falls ihr Flecken an der Wand habt, hier vor allem, dann wisst ihr, dass es der Wasserschaden ist und dann raus aber schnell.
Und dann haben die aber die ganze Zeit Angst, weil ich kenne das nämlich auch mit psychosomatischen Leiden. Wenn ich eine Doku sehe über Herzinfarkte, dann kriege ich Herzbeklemmungen. Und dann denke ich mir, ach, davon sprechen die, das habe ich ja jetzt gerade auch. Und seitdem bist du ein bisschen Armschienen im Schlafen. Genau. Und deswegen denke ich mir, ich will jetzt natürlich nicht, weil wenn dir jemand sagt, übrigens in der Wohnung, könnte es sein, dass da Schimmel ist, tschüss, wie schläfst du denn die Nacht? Bei jedem Atemzug denkst du dir, ich fühle mich nicht gut eigentlich. Deswegen weiß ich nicht. Ja, nur dass Schimmel halt auch wirklich gefährlich ist und man das Leuten sagen sollte. Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, dass der Vermieter das unter den Teppich kehrt. Es gibt richtig tolle Möglichkeiten, ich weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert, aber es gibt diese Firma, die legt die Wände dann trocken und die holen da alles an Feuchtigkeit raus mit geballten Chemikalien, Power, was auch immer und dann hast du zehn Jahre Garantie darauf, dass es trocken bleibt. Es gibt so richtig coole Firmen, die das können. Die sind teuer und wenn es ein Arschloch ist, dann hat er wahrscheinlich das Geld nicht investiert und hat einfach übermalt und hofft, es ist chemitrocken. Ich hoffe nur für die Nachmieter, dass sie nicht das Podcast so verhören. Weil wenn sie an irgendeinem Punkt erfahren, es ist sehr gut dokumentiert, nicht nur der Wasserschaden, sondern alles, was in dieser Wohnung weirdes passiert wurde. Und wie du, ich erinnere mich nämlich noch an ein paar Sachen, wie du angefangen hast, Dinge aus dem Fenster zu werfen, wie du da mit einem Schwert herumgespielt hast. Naja, ich muss üben. So ein Schwertarm kriegst du nicht von alleine. Und ich glaube, Wohnungen, Mietwohnungen oder Hotels funktionieren überhaupt nur, weil du nicht weißt, was vorher passiert ist. Absolut. So, was du nicht weißt, macht dich nicht heist. Wenn dir dein Vormieter sagt, übrigens, ganz kurz, also meine Freundin und ich hatten Sex hier, hier, hier zweimal, da, da oben. Das ist ein zu genauer Übergabeprotokoll. Genau. Wo haben die hin ejakuliert? Ohne ihre Freundin? Fragen Sie lieber, wo nicht. Ja genau, gerne nicht. Also wenn Sie hier kurz Kreuzen machen könnten, wo nicht. Also die Heizung ist randvoll. Also das war, weil es warm ist. Genau, die Heizung, da war warm und dann habe ich so. Die Heizung ist komplett voll, das Röhrensystem dürfte auch komplett randvoll sein. Dann haben Sie ja über dem Schrank, da haben Sie so Rillen für diesen Lüftungsschacht, randvoll. Ah, okay, ganz voll, alles klar. Dann möchte ich noch den Schlüssel zur Garage, dann hätten wir es. Genau, der Schlüssel zur Garage ist hier und ja, den auch, hätte ich dazu sagen müssen, der auch, ja genau, sorry. Dann viel Spaß, dann viel Spaß in ihrer neuen Wohnung, willst du nicht wissen. Und da sagst du nämlich, was du nicht weißt, macht dich nicht heiß, du willst gewisse Dinge nicht wissen. Was du nicht weißt, macht dich schwanger. So, kann sein, wenn du dann an der Heizung dich einmal draufsetzt. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich will nicht wissen, was vor mir passiert ist. Deswegen, ich finde auch so Dreck nicht schlimm in Hotelzimmern. Also, der Dreck an sich ist nicht schlimm. Aber der Fakt, dass es dir auch nur sagt, hier war vorher jemand drin, was du ja weißt. Das ist ein Hotel ein Hotel, ein Steilhotel, da wurde gefickt, da wurde ... Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Da ist alles Schlimme passiert, was du nicht willst. Du weißt es ja, aber auch nur das leiseste Anzeichen von Vorbesitzern, strecklich. Das ist so die warme Toilettenbrille. Die Wärme selbst ist eigentlich nicht das Problem, ganz im Gegenteil. Eine warme Klobrille wäre wunderbar, aber es ist eben das Wissen, das mitschwingt. Oder Beispiel Haar in der Suppe. Haare sind nicht widerlich, überhaupt nicht widerlich. Es ist nur, dass es dir so offen suggeriert, dass da gerade ein Mensch mit seinen Patschehändchen und seinem, was er noch hat, Haare. Schorf. Es ist nur der Beweis, ein Mensch war an deiner Suppe. Was du ja auch willst. Du willst ja keine maschinelle Suppe, sondern du willst eine menschengemachte, handgemachte Suppe. Du willst nur keinen Beweis von der Hand. Das ist so komisch. Deswegen, schwierig, ich bin mal gespannt auf das Feedback aus der Community und ich bin natürlich auch gespannt auf das Feedback. Also, falls jetzt jemand in Köln gerade eine neue Wohnung bezieht und in zwei Wochen fängt es an zu schimmeln, dann denken die dann, das war meine Wohnung? Also versuchen die so Rückschlüsse zu machen? Weiß ich nicht, schreibt mir gerne. Aber ich finde das auch immer mit diesem Handsuppe, irgendwo finde ich, ist das eine ganz merkwürdige Werbung auch immer so. Ich habe zum Beispiel letztens eine Packung Schinken mir geholt und da stand drauf, Schinken handgelegt. Heißt es, dass jemand mit der Hand den Schinken in die Packung reingelegt hat? Nee, nicht in die Packung, oder? Also das ist so eine Plastikpackung, wo dann so fünf Scheiben sind. Aber über so ein Stein, wo dann getrocknet wurden oder so. Aber was genau wurde wohin gelegt? Also handgelegt ist so ein ... Ich finde, ist das ein Übersetzungsfehler einfach? Nee, auf dem Schinken steht Wacholder-Schinken, handgelegt. Handgelegt. Und ich denke, also Maschinen können vieles nicht, aber legen können die. Also ich habe wirklich, wenn jemand sagt, also von mir aus Schlachtung oder so, wenn das ein Mensch macht, keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist es besser, aber legen, also ja klar, lass es die Maschine legen.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, die haben so einen ewigen langen Produktionsprozess und haben geguckt, wo ist noch ein Mensch. Und an einer Stelle legt ein Mensch den Schinken aus der Todesmühle, aus dem Blutgrinder und nimmt einmal den Schinken und legt ihn irgendwo in eine Kiste. Hand gelegt. Der hat mit der Hand gelegt. Wie kann man das mit dem Hand ausgepackt? Na, streng, dann packt der Roboter das aus. Angepackt. Packt Derrick, dieser Roboter das aus. Er hat es eigentlich nur gelegt, ne? Hand gelegt. Ja, das ist der ... derrick, du sollst doch nicht zuhören, wenn wir uns unterhalten. Ja, sorry, Sir. Derrick, jetzt fang an, die Schweine zu schlachten. Ja, meister. Fang an, die wegzumetzeln. Die müssen alle sterben. Ich bringe sie alle um, auch die Kinder. Ja, auch die Kinder, auch die Kleinen. Ja, lass sie quieken, lass sie quieken. Ich glaube, dieser Roboter wird uns niemals Probleme bereiten, niemals. Aber er brachte ihnen Probleme. Aber dann brachte er ihnen doch Probleme. Finanzielle Probleme. Ich meine, der Film war spannend, packend
und zeitkritisches Thema,
aber 90 Minuten
lang diese Stimme ist
einfach, es ist einfach
warum hat der Roboter extra nochmal
einen Roboterarm, wo er sich
mit einem Roboterfinger über die Lippen
geht die ganze Zeit, also was
war das denn? Also ich meine, das
macht den ja auch nicht furchteinflössend oder so, das ist einfach ein merkwürdiger Effekt. Wir wollten den menschlich zeichnen. Warum denn? Es geht doch... Handgelegt. Handgelegte Stimme. Ja, menschliche Robert, das ist so ein Ding. Ich hab Star Wars Episode 1, da gibt's ja am Anfang die Szene, ne? Qui-Gon Jinn. Lass mich kurz nochmal nachrechnen. Episode 1. The Phantom Menace, der mit Jar Jar Binks. Da gibt es ja am Anfang Handelsföderation, Qui-Gon Jinn, Obi-Wan Kenobi sind da auf diplomatische Missionen in den Raum. Treffen TC-14. Und dann, genau, bringt dieser Silberne Roboter einen Tee und der hat eine weibliche TC-14. Und der hat ja eine weibliche Stimme. Aber der sieht ja genauso aus wie C3PO. Und der hat eine männliche Stimme. Ja, aber Siri kann es ja auch auf einen Mann stellen. So, das ist einfach, aber anatomisch ist alles gleich. Ich glaube, Roboter sind erst mal geschlechtslos. Ja, na klar. Stimmen sind aber nicht geschlechtslos. Das heißt, bei C3PO kann ja auch Soundeffekte imitieren. Sonst wäre es C-3PA.
Er ist eine spanische Herkunft, da kann man das immer gut
ablesen. Aber C-3PO, bei den Evox
imitiert er ja auch 80-80s und
TIE Fighter. Der spricht ja nicht wie
ein Mensch, sondern der hat einfach einen Lautsprecher.
Das heißt, man kann dem unterschiedliche Stimmen
geben. Aber mich wundert es
trotzdem, C-3PO
wurde ja von Anakin Skywalker gebaut, in Episode 1. Wie kann denn dann dieser andere Roboter genauso aussehen wie der? Oder hat der die Teile von diesem C-14 bekommen dann? Nein, nein, der ist ja silbern auch. Und wir wollen ja, wir denken ja an den goldenen, unseren goldenen C3-Piro. Oder hat Anakin den nach dem Vorbild von diesem Roboter gebaut? Ich glaube, Protokoll-Droiden, das ist wie, die haben halt diese Rüstung. Aber wer hat die erfunden? Anakin Skywalker oder? eine Firma, Apple, Tesla, was auch immer, und die sehen halt so aus.
Ich sag mal, wer hat die erfunden? Anakin Skywalker oder? Ach so. Eine Firma, Apple, Tesla,
was auch immer, und die sehen
halt so aus. Ich sag mal,
so ein Computer, den du baust,
das Gehäuse sieht ja auch immer
ähnlich aus, der Tower. Ah, okay.
Das Gebäude ist ja immer irgendwie gleich.
Der Protokoll-Droide hat bestimmte Funktionen,
muss bestimmte Sachen machen und soll
menschlich wirken. Ist ja ein Roboter-Mensch-
Kontakter. Das heißt, Anakin baut das Innenleben und irgendwann hat dann jemand gesagt, pack da die Hülle von so einem C-14 drauf. Er wollte immer ein Protokollruiden bauen, glaube ich, genau. Und dann gehst du irgendwann in den Laden und kaufst eine gebrauchte Hülle eines Protokollruiden und die sehen halt immer schätze ich gleich aus, so bis ich mir immer hergeleitet. Ja. Und dann hat er sich das zusammengebaut. Jetzt ist TC4 natürlich wahnsinnig schön, da spiegelt sie dich ja förmlich drin. Ja, ja, ja. Und der erste C3PO, den wir kennen, hat, glaube ich, noch eine sehr rudimentäre, dreckige Oberfläche. Ist natürlich spannend, weil als Zuschauer denkst du, ah, der sieht aus wie C3PO, aber zeitlich ist es andersrum, weil C3PO mal so so aussehen wird, wie der jetzt aussieht. So, das heißt, eigentlich denkst du, wow, du kennst ja, du hast ja erst vier, fünf, sechs gesehen. So, das heißt, eigentlich bist du ja komplett falsch rum und Anakin baut den erst nach. Das ist eh alles ein bisschen verdreht, weil die Episode eins bis drei sehen ja viel bunter, poppiger, future-mässiger aus. Ja. Und dann kommt das viel spätere, wo ja man denkt, ah, da ist viel passiert, es müsste ja noch fortschrittlicher sein, sieht dann eher runtergerockt und so nitty-gritty aus. Ja. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen verwirrend für Menschen wie dich, die da keine Fantasie an den Tag legen. Die keine Medichlorianer im Blut haben. Die wenig Medichlorianer im Blut haben. Und dann gibt's ja noch bei Rex Becks, diesem Diner, da gibt's ja auch diesen Und wie gross sein Portemonnaie ist! Und da gibt's ja auch diesen weiblichen Kellner-Druiden, die ist ja ganz klar, ganz klar sieht die wie eine menschliche Frau aus. Das heißt, da ist auch ganz klar auf weiblich gepolt. Ich finde das ein ganz spannendes Thema, wann man in der Zukunft dann sagt, wann soll es eine männliche Stimme haben, wann eine weibliche Stimme, und kann man jedem Druiden so klar eine Rolle zuweisen, oder wie gibt es auch neutrale Stimmen? Auch schwierig. Welche, also die ganzen von der Handelsföderation, diese Roger-Roger-Druiden, die sind ja eher männlich dann, oder? Die sind eher männlich, die haben männliche Stimmen, Roger-Roger, sagen die immer. Sollen ja auch Soldaten zeigen. So, das ist natürlich die Frage, wie haben sich die Geschlechterbilder entwickelt? Ich finde es ein bisschen problematisch. Warum macht man das so? Du hast natürlich, die Soldaten sind alle männlich. Die Kellner sind weiblich. Die Kellner und Kehrleute sind weiblich. Genau, Duba, der Hebammenroboter ist auch weiblich eher. Genau. Du hast weibliche Roboter, die weibliche gelesene Jobs irgendwie machen.
Da muss man sich schon Gedanken machen, wenn du so eine Zukunftswelt baust, fragst du ja auch viel über die Gegenwart aus, weil du überlegst, wie werden denn die aktuellen Prozesse gelöst oder weiterentwickelt. Über die Bilder, das Weltbild desjenigen aus, der die Stimmen programmiert.
Wohingegen, wenn du eine Geschichte aus der Vergangenheit erzählst, easy.
Weil da kannst du ja all in Geschlechterrollen oder all in Klischees, weil du da sagst, zu früher war das halt so. Wohingegen in der Zukunft musst du ja selber die Entscheidung treffen, deswegen würde ich glaube ich nichts in der Zukunft schreiben. Da müsste ich zu viele gesellschaftliche Entscheidungen treffen. Nee, ich kenne mich auch einfach zu wenig aus. Muss ja nicht, das ist deine Gedankenwelt. Ja gut, aber dann sage ich, sollen dann die Soldaten weibliche Stimmen haben? Was genau soll das jetzt sein? Oder gibt es neutrale Stimmen? Neutrale Stimmen, wäre doch sehr geil. Wie macht man das? Du nimmst Celine Dion und Michael Bublé und legst sie in Audition übereinander, oder was? Du erzählst doch immer, dass man für die Sarumanen slash Gander,
Christopher Lee und Sir Ian McKellen übereinander gelegt hat.
Okay, das ist ein ganz anderes Thema.
Ja, egal. Aber das, genau, das erzählst du mir ja immer.
Da kann man ja auch genau so eine Frau und Mann übereinander legen.
Okay, also gibt es eine Stimme, die man keinem Geschlecht zuordnen kann?
Share?
Ja, ich finde, Share ist sehr gut.
Ist neutral.
Share ist recht neutral.
Das ist ein W übereinander legen. Okay, also gibt es eine Stimme, die man keinem Geschlecht zuordnen kann? Scheer? Ja, ich finde Scheer ist sehr gut. Ist neutral. Scheer ist recht neutral. Da gibt es bestimmt Studien und so, da gibt es bestimmt linguistische Sachen, weil die müssen sich ja genau beschäftigen, wann wird eine Stimme als was wahrgenommen, ob es neutral gibt. Das ist ja häufig so, dass weiblich gelesene Personen sprechen häufig genau ein Otterbe höher als wenn ich gelesene Personen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch schon das ganze Geheimnis. Aber ich glaube, du kannst unabhängig auch von der Tonhöhe das Geschlecht feststellen. Das weiß ich. Oder eine gute Schätzung abgeben. Bei so Navigationssystemen zum Beispiel bin ich oft mit Lars Eric Pauls im Auto gefahren und der hatte als Navigationssystem Marcel Reich-Ranitzki. Da hat dann irgendjemand eine Liste bekommen von allen möglichen Anweisungen, die so ein Navigationsgerät gibt und hat das dann eingelesen mit der Stimme von Marcel Reich-Ranitzki. Ich nehme an, dass nicht der echte Marcel Reich-Ranitzki zwei Stunden im Tonstudium... Er hat alle Wörter in seinem Hörbuch bestimmt mal eingelesen. Wirklich? Erbiegen Sie jetzt in den Marianengraben ab. Biegen Sie jetzt in die Rudolf-Moosleitner-Strasse ab. Okay, okay, lieber. Er wird schon wissen. Ich glaube, das ist schon ein ganz schrecklicher. Irgendwo in irgendeinem Tonstudio, wahrscheinlich in Köln, hat irgendein wahrscheinlich mittelmässiger Stimmenimitator sämtliche Strassen Deutschlands als Marcel Reich-Ranitzki eingelesen. Der Bergenallee. Wo ich mir denke, also wann erschießt man sich einfach und sagt, was mache ich hier, weil du kannst ja nicht sagen, ich habe keinen Bock mehr nach zehn Stunden. Ja, wir haben jetzt noch 200 Stunden vor uns. Ich will ja raus! Gott, oh Gott. Ich will ja raus! Wie viele Stunden am Tag kann man so was machen? Was war das für ein ... Das klingt aber nach, wenn ich vor zehn Jahren oder so. Ja, ja, ja, klar. Wo man dann auch noch so ... Da hatten alle lustige Handy-Klingeltöne und so was. Und dann lässt man das Navi anders einstellen. Was für eine absolut miserable Zeit. Wasgendein Mensch muss über Wochen hinweg ach Gott. Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Okay, ähm, ja gut. Würde ich jetzt sagen, eher männliche Stimme. Marcel Reichenitzki, ja, auf jeden Fall. Ja, ich finde die Frage gut. Also eine neutrale Stimme, und es müsste ja inzwischen gehen, mit KI. Mit KI-Technologie. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Doch, wir können uns mal informieren und machen die nächste Folge komplett in neutralen Stimmen. In neutralen Stimmen. Gut, da müssen wir natürlich jetzt viel lernen, viel üben. Ich habe ja tatsächlich mein Traum ist es ja eines, also ich habe ja immer so quatschige Sachen, aber dann habe ich auch manchmal so ernste Projekte, die ich gerne angehe. Okayabe ich jetzt schon lange nicht mehr gemacht. Aber ich dachte mir, weil es gibt nämlich ganz gut, also was heißt gute, ich kann das nicht bewerten, aber es gibt deutsche Übersetzungen von Shakespeare, die sind eigentlich alle Crap, aber es gibt einen Übersetzer, den finde ich ziemlich gut. Und ich habe überlegt, könnte man nicht als Deutsche, als ein Hörspiel von einem Shakespeare-Stück auf Deutsch machen. Weil viele Leute können mit Shakespeare natürlich nichts anfangen, weil du raffst gar nichts, selbst wenn du dich ein bisschen auskennst, raffst du nichts. Aber wenn du es auf Deutsch zumindest hörst, kannst du zumindest halbwegs checken, was los ist und was die ganzen Metaphern überhaupt bedeuten sollen. Deswegen glaube ich, könnte das ein cooler Einstieg sein. Hörbücher. Hörbücher, also Hörspiele. Hörspiele. Und dann habe ich überlegt, ja gut, das würde ich gerne alles selber einsprechen, alle Rollen. Und dann habe ich auch so ein bisschen überlegt, ja gut, was mache ich denn mit den weiblichen Rollen? So, ich hab nämlich jetzt, ich bin grosser Fan von Twitch-Rollenspiel-Servern, nämlich Leute, die dann bei Red Dead Redemption oder GTA oder so auf Rollenspiel-Servern, gemoddeten Rollenspiel-Servern spielen.
Und da wirklich in die geilsten Rollen ein.
Das ist wie Improv-Theater.
Super langatmig, grosse Erzählstränge.
Es macht richtig Spaß.
Und auch gerade Red Dead Redemption ist ein ganz tolles Spiel dafür,
weil es atmosphärisch ist und auch eh schon so langsam.
Und dann reiten die eine Stunde nebeneinander her irgendwo hin
und nichts wiederholt sich, sondern die Karte ist ja auch so gross und dann reden sie und das ist ganz toll. Und da hat mein Lieblings-Twitcher jetzt zum ersten Mal eine Frau gespielt. Mit einem Voice-Modulator, der einfach was er sagt, quasi ist wie so ein Stimmenverzerrer. Und das habe ich aber noch nie gut gehört. Generell auch Stimmenverzerrer. Und das war jetzt, er hat eine Frau und das klingt absolut perfekt. Jetzt sieht man ihn dann dabei immer, wie er da spricht. Und das macht so ein bisschen die, deswegen bin ich mal zu den anderen Charakteren, den anderen Twitch-Streamern gegangen, die dann filmen, wie sie ihm begegnen. Und man hört an der Weise, wie er spricht, also das Vokabular oder so, eher, dass es ein Mann ist, als eine Stimme. Du hörst, manchmal glitscht es so, dann hast du wie so Autotune. Dann hörst du kurz Marcel Reich-Ranitzki zwischendurch. Genau.
Igelling, Zappi, Igelinek.
Ich kann mir das nicht mehr ertragen.
Das ist ein bisschen ... Wirft einen ein bisschen raus.
Komischerweise ist in jeder Art Stimmsoftware
irgendwo so der Geist von Marcel Reich-Ranitzki drin.
Man kriegt den auch nicht raus.
Nicht nur in Stimmsoftware.
Aus der Hardware ist überall.
Der Geist von Marcel Reich-Ranitzki ist überall
und ich finde es nicht schlecht. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Er begleitet uns weiterhin. So, und das ist total spannend, wie er, weil er war am Anfang auch sehr nervös. Wenn er Frauen begegnet, man weiss, es sind Streamerinnen oder Streamer, die jetzt nicht wissen, wer er ist. Und dann eher so, die wissen, dass ich keine Frau bin. Ich glaube nämlich nicht. Ich glaube nicht. Ja, man muss es nicht weiss, ja. Und es gibt ja auch gerade oft so Sozialexperimente, irgendwie bei YouTube oder TikTok oder sowas, wo man herausfinden muss, wer ist die Frau. So ein Maulwurf. Und dann gibt es das mit Stimmmodulationssachen oder einfach ein Mann, war mal so eine Gruppe Frau, alle hatten so diese Wetten-das-Brillen auf und er konnte einfach sehr gut wie eine Frau sprechen und kam, ist glaube ich nicht aufgeflogen, er hat auch gelacht wie eine Frau. Und dann erzählte er immer so dazwischen so ernst, ja und das die schlimmste Momente war, wenn sie alle lachen, die haben viel gelacht. Die haben viel gelacht und dann musste er dann immer so hoch mitlachen. Ah, okay, ja. Ja, es ist super beeindruckend. Ich habe, wie gesagt, als Teil dieses Projekts gibt es ja auch ganz viele YouTube-Videos so aus der Trans-Community, so wie man dann spricht, wie man das lernen kann und so. Und das habe ich auch versucht, sofort aufgegeben, sofort aufgeben, weil es super schwer ist und man am Anfang natürlich auch noch keine Resultate da bekommt. Ich glaube, du musst da wirklich lange auch deinen Stimmapparat irgendwie üben und trainieren irgendwie. Aber es ist schon echt beeindruckend. Aber gut, liegt auf Eis alles. Dein Shakespeare-Projekt liegt jetzt auch wieder auf Eis. Offiziell on Eis. Ich finde gut, dass Shakespeare on Eis. Das könnte jetzt natürlich irrefühlen. Anderes Projekt. Kauft keine Tickets. Stopp. Kauft keine Tickets für Shakespeare on Eis. Was ich damit meine, ist, es liegt auf Eis. Es ist in der Kryokammer. Ja. Es liegt in der Kryokammer. Es liegt auf Eis. Nein. Im Sinne von Langsess-Arena. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, nein. Ich sehe Show. Stellt euch Shrimps vor, nein, es liegt wie Walt Disney. Stellt ne, ne, Walt Disney on Ice. Leggings. Leggings, tragende Männer auf Eis. Nein, nein, nein, stopp, stopp, stopp, Walt Disney on Ice. Also es ist wirklich wie Walt Disney on Eis. Es ist genauso wie Disney on Eis. Nein, stopp. Auf Eis. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Es ist durch. Ja, schade, weil, und das zeigt auch, weil Shakespeare hat ja zu seiner Lebzeit sehr viel geschrieben. Und du kriegst es nicht mal hin, das, was der Mann geschrieben hat, als Hörbuch, was du nicht übersetzt hast. Ja, du hast recht, ich bleibe mal wieder hinter Shakespeare zurück. Und wieder eine Folge, in der ich feststellen muss, dass ich nicht so gut bin wie Shakespeare und jedes Mal ... Das war der Punkt. Shakespeare, wenn es eine Skala ist, ist Shakespeare, der wie viele Sachen geschrieben hat, wie viele Gedicht, Bände und Werke, die stehen da, aber er war ja eh wahrscheinlich zehn Leute. Ja, ach so, na! Okay, acht. Die stehen, das ist sozusagen die Skala ganz rechts. Dann kommt die, die es übersetzt haben, dann kommt die, die sich damit beschäftigen, die damit, weiss ich, die Sprache untersucht haben, die geforscht haben. Und dann ganz, ganz links kommst du, der die... Du meinst, ich bin das Gegenteil von Will. Ja, genau, der sich überlegt, ja man könnte ja was machen, was dann auf Eis liegt. Wenn ich vielleicht irgendwie Schauspielerin finde oder so. Ich meine, ironischerweise zu dem Männer-Frauen-Thema war es ja so, dass in Shakespeare-Zeiten Frauen keine Schauspieler sein durften, sondern Männerfrauen gespielt haben, sondern Jungs, also junge Männer, die Frauenrollen gespielt haben. Was natürlich immer so, das wird ständig betont, wenn man sich so Interpretationen durchliest von so, es ist ja bei Shakespeare oft so Gender-Swap-Comedy, dass sich jemand als Frau ausgibt, der ein Mann ist und so, was natürlich immer noch mal eine
Ebene drüber ist, weil es ja tatsächlich
von einem Jungen gespielt wird. Das heisst, du hast immer
einen Jungen, der eine Frau spielt, der einen Mann spielt,
der eine Frau spielt und dann gibt es Kussszene
und dann denkt man sich, sollte das jetzt so ein bisschen
witzig sein oder nicht?
Niemand weiss es oder so, aber man
denkt da immer so mit irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
deswegen ist das immer noch mal so eine Ebene drüber.
Jetzt solltest du, finde ich, dein Hörbuch ausschließlich mit Schauspielerinnen machen. Richtig, die auch die Männerrollen spielen. Genau, das wäre eigentlich konsequent. Das heißt, auch hier habe ich wieder nichts damit zu tun. Das heißt, ich gebe die Idee weiter, falls es Shakespeare-Fans da draußen gibt, ich gebe das an euch weiter. Du gibst alles ab, du bist der Gegenteil. Richtig, absolut. Du machst nichts. Ich liege auf Eis, Shakespeare alles. Flotin liegt auf Eis. Ich bin komplett auf Eis. Damit verabschiede ich mich von dieser Folge. Ich bin raus. Flotin ist raus. Ich bin auf Eis. Die Folge ist das Podcast-Ufo, liegt jetzt immer für eine Woche auf Eis. Komplett auf Eis. Ich mache nichts, wenn wir diese Woche überleben. Was du nicht weißt, liegt auf Eis. Wunderbar. Vielen Dank für die Folge an dich, Florentin.
Liebe Grüße ans mexikanische Kartell, wir haben euch lieb.
Liebe Grüße ans mexikanische Kartell.
Wir wollen euch nichts böses.
We love to entertain you.
We love to live.
Das war Folge 439.
Oder drei.
Was seid ihr beschuldigt?
Mama!
Warum schläfst du denn nicht? Warum schläfst du denn nicht?
Weil ich nicht schlafen kann.
Ach, aber leise.